dearest viewer this author finds herself
compelled to share the most curious of
news
it seems that netflix is scandalously
fashionable show bridgeton is positively
brimming with hidden easter eggs and
secret details you might have missed the
most exhilarating of which i shall now
uncover
be forewarned dear viewer for there are
spoilers ahead
there are bees buzzing around everywhere
in bridgeton from the opening scene of
the series to the show's title sequence
through to the very final scene of
season one
they even feature on eloise's hair
accessories and benedict's collar
the first bee appears on the door of the
bridgeton household just as lady
whistled down mentions the widowed by
countess a neat reference to how violet
became a widow after her husband died
from a bee sting in the novels it shows
based on
also at the start of the final episode
when whistle down talks about the
fastest courtship on record
notice this bee on the roses decorating
the just married couple's carriage
of course miss leopold and her new
husband would leave london
mere hours after their wedding reason
unknown given the crucial role of bees
in pollination and therefore how
culturally they're linked with
reproduction
this clip clearly suggests that the
couple left so quickly as she was
pregnant or about to become so
which is why a bee appears again at the
end of the episode just after daphne
gives birth
and that last shot in the season finale
is also a big hint that in season two
anthony's story will follow what happens
in the second book where his fear of
bees after his father's death
leads him into a scandalous situation
with a new love interest
and bees aren't the only insects with
added meaning in the series
the featherington family's flamboyant
fashions can be quite a lot to take in
so you may have missed the fact that
butterflies often
form part of their outfits especially
penelope's
from her various hair accessories to
several of her necklaces
and the many large and small ones on
this dress here
it's certainly fitting that the show
associates butterflies with the
featheringtons as not only are the
insects often highly colourful but also
because of their short lifespans and
ephemeral beauty
they can be symbols of empty vanity as
to why they're linked to penelope in
particular
the fact butterflies often symbolize
transformation
freedom and new beginnings is a hint
that penelope's not exactly what at
first she appears to be
at the beginning of the show she seems
to be a debutant that few people pay
attention to penelope i did not see you
there but by the end of season one
our perception of her has been
transformed as we discover that she's
the author of society's most popular
scandal sheet
whose words everyone listens to and
thanks to that secret identity she
enjoys a level of freedom she never had
before
a scribbling woman is the most canine if
that should be true
then this author would like to show you
her teeth when it came to dressing the
featherington family costume designer
ella mirage nick went deliberately over
the top
aiming for a gaudy over decorated
overzealous look to convey the fact
their nouveau riche
and to create a sharp contrast with the
refinement of the more well-established
bridgeton family
so feathering to matriarch porsche goes
for bright colours
bold patterns and lots of embellishments
and she wants her daughters to stand out
so she can marry them off
the bridgeton family's look is more
elegant and muted
leaning into a pretty pristine powdery
palette of pale blues
silvers and greens and when it comes to
daphne specifically as her character
matures she goes for duskier colours
with
richer pinks and blues and deeper
silvers as costume designer miroznik
puts it she begins as a porcelain doll
and becomes a woman
as for eloise who's smart rebellious and
speaks her mind perhaps you should like
me to picture
her clothes tend to be simple in shape
and quite covered up
and rather than being sent out and
decorated she gets what the designer
calls a masculine twist
then the simon whose rich velvet fabrics
and brocades as well as the colours
patterns and cuts of his clothes stand
out as they're influenced by his travels
abroad according to mirage nick
reds and golds which are his family
colours in the novels are quite often
part of his outfits though according to
the costume designer the real reason for
that
is that the very first time they tried
red on actor reggae jean-page in a
fitting he just looks so good in it
on top of that leficialusa.com describes
simon's darker mature palette as
providing a contrast to daphne's frothy
pieces which points towards the dynamic
of their relationship
and if you're wondering about the
significance of the diamond and emerald
encrusted in our brooch that simon can
often be seen wearing on his lapel
it belonged to his late mother so acts
as a reminder of her
due to sharoner chris van dusen's
obsession with the bbc adaptation of
pride and prejudice from the 1990s
simon gets his very own mr darcy style
moment
though van dusen wanted to see a period
piece that went even further than that
so this time the wet white shirt isn't
caused by plunging into a lake
instead simon gets caught in a sudden
downpour during some alfresco
late night loving with his new wife
tulips are mentioned a few times in the
show but this exchange between violet
bridgeton and her son anthony
particularly caught my attention
tulips they symbolize passion most
appropriate hem for your sister when she
decides to marry the duke
perhaps your bride would like the same
this seemingly small moment is very
significant as it's a big clue to what
will happen in season two of the show
why is that well because it's a hat tip
to the novels where violet has filled
the garden of her country home with one
of her favorite flowers tulips
and in the second book of the bridgeton
saga anthony picks a tulip for his new
love interest
so in the first episode during one of
anthony's trysts with sienna when you
see his watch on this piece of furniture
with a tulip-like design
it's a subtle hint that his time with
her will soon be over
as his new love interest in the second
season will be the woman he gives a
tulip to
in the books when anthony tells his
youngest sister hyacinths she can join
in with the summer fun at their country
home
as long as she stays clear of his lucky
mallet that's a nod to the croquet-like
game of pal mal that the bridgeton's
love to play in the novels and has
become a real fan favorite moment
according to author julia quinn
that game which in the second novel
daphne says is full of bad sportsmanship
cheating and lying and is less about
winning than making sure the other
players lose plays an important role in
anthony's love life so it'll very likely
pop up in the second season
especially as quinn our showrunner
vandusen to make sure it does
during a flashback to simon's childhood
we learn his father had him hidden away
because of his stammer
instead of going to school then his
governors taught him and his lessons
included latin which was usual for boys
at the time
an interesting detail that signals the
kind of man simon will grow up to be are
the latin conjugations on the blackboard
for the word pugnare which means to
fight to battle to strive or struggle
as a child simon strove to overcome his
stammer and lack of confidence with the
help of lady danbury
and as an adult he not only gets
involved in boxing but he also ends up
in a jewel with anthony
so this shot shows how simon has in a
way been learning the meaning of
fighting since he was a child
during a raunchy rendezvous it's no
coincidence that anthony crashes into a
poster for mozart's opera don giovanni
on sienna's dressing room wall that
particular opera is based on the legend
of don juan a young licentious nobleman
who places pleasure above all
else which anthony certainly does for
much of the first season
you like to speak of responsibility my
dear son
pray tell what should you know of it the
way the framed poster tumbles to the
floor could also be a little hint to how
anthony and siena's relationship
will eventually come crashing down the
line for three nights only on the poster
also foreshadows the temporary nature of
their affair
there's another clever bit of
foreshadowing on the dance cards and the
ballroom floor at danbury house where a
latin phrase appears which means we do
not learn for school but for life
this fits the show well because as
showrunner van dusen says season one
focuses on the education of daphne
bridgeton
who starts out as this young innocent
debutant who knows very little of love
and nothing of sex
titled chaste and innocent this is what
they have been raised and trained for
since
birth then as van dusen says over the
course of the series we watch her
transform entirely
now what did you think of bridgeton and
did you notice any little details or
easter eggs leave your comments below
and if you enjoyed this don't forget to
leave a thumbs up it's hugely
appreciated
tap left for my next netflix video
including a full breakdown of the
sabrina series finale and a potential
part 5
or tap right for something else you're
sure to like thanks for watching and see
you next time yippee kai movie lovers